Good morning, Hank. It's Tuesday.
Today is the ninth day of Pizzamas, so to
celebrate, today’s video comes to you in
nine very special parts.
That was part one, the intro.
Part Two: Unabashed Promotion of Saleable
Goods.
So there are only a few days left to order
all your Pizzamas stuff from dftba.com.
All these beautiful Pizza John shirts and
the Pizza John PJs and everything else is
only available ‘til the end of Pizzamas.
Part Three: Good News.
So I don’t want to minimize or ignore the
torrent of bad news currently washing over
the world, but I did want to call your attention
to one piece of extraordinarily good news
that I think has gone underreported.
It’s just been announced that global carbon
emissions are expected to be nearly flat in
2016, marking the third straight year of no
carbon emission growth.
That’s really good news.
Unfortunately, it’s not good enough news,
because emissions are still far too high
to limit post-industrial warming to below
two degrees celsius.
But it’s important because it underscores
that humanity can reach its other goals without
increasing emissions.
Like, the global economy grew by about 3%
this year, and both poverty and disease burden
were reduced.
Part Three (four): Bad News.
The UN has just reported that 2016 will almost
certainly be the hottest year in recorded
human history.
And worrisomely, that record will likely only
stand until 2017.
Climate change is real, humans are causing
it, and the people of the future will judge
us on how we dealt with it.
Part Five: More Good News.
AFC Wimbledon, the fan-owned English soccer
team who wear DFTBA on their shorts have had
an astonishingly successful first season in
the third tier of English football.
Seventeen games into the season, they are
just three points from a playoff spot, while
the franchise currently playing in Milton
Keynes is in the relegation zone.
All of this is just further proof that we
are living in the best sports timeline of
the entire multiverse, and also the worst
everything else timeline.
Part Six: Unabashed Promotion of Saleable
Goods.
While you’re over at dftba.com picking up
this comfortable and fashionable Pizza John
hoodie, why not buy an AFC WImbledon Nerdfighteria
scarf?
All proceeds go to the club, and maybe if
we sell enough scarves, they will make it
back to the playoffs, and I will get to go
to Wembley and feel like this again.
Part Seven: More Bad News.
So Hank, one of my favorite songwriters, Leonard
Cohen, died last week.
He was everything I wanna be when I grow up:
empathetic and smart without ever being condescending
or cold, and he also gave me one the central
ideas in my book Paper Towns.
I’m gonna put a link to some of my favorite
Leonard Cohen songs in the dooblydoo below
for you to enjoy.
Part Eight: More Good News.
Amid loss, there is still great art being
made in the world.
Quick side story, when I was fifteen, I wrote
this extremely sincere and terrible paper
for English about how there could never be
another great work of fiction because Dostoyevsky
was dead.
And then like four months later, we read Toni
Morrison’s Song of Solomon, and Tony
Kushner’s Angels in America, and I was like,
“Oh, oh, okay.
I would like to file a retraction.”
Anyway, twenty years later, Dostoyevsky is
still dead and there are still truly great
books being written.
Most recently I had been completely astonished
by this book: What Is Not Yours Is Not Yours,
but I’ll have many more book recommendations
in my forthcoming holiday gift book roundup.
In the meantime, if there are books that you
would suggest to me, please do so in comments.
Thanks.
Part Nine: The Outtro.
So I think I’m gonna close out my part of
Pizzamas on Thursday with an old-fashioned
Question Tuesday, because, you know, what
better day to do it?
So please leave your questions, ideally brief
ones in the comment section below.
And I thought I’d leave you today with some
of my favorite Leonard Cohen lines:
Ring the bells that still can ring.
Forget your perfect offering.
There’s a crack in everything.
That’s how the light gets in.
Endscreen!
Oh look it’s that book that I liked and
Pizzamas merch and a couple of my favorite
Leonard Cohen songs and perhaps most importantly,
a bunny from Rosianna.
Self-Care Bunny is here to remind you to take
care of yourself because there is only one
of you, and the world is lucky to have you.